[Music]
it must be a dream come true to work in
the most magical place in the world
every day but Disney cast members
probably have a different opinion
because they know what is really
happening there make sure you watch this
video until the end to know what
happened when they had to share
underwear if you love Disney as much as
we do don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we're showing you 10 secrets
revealed by former Disney employees the
love we all wish that we could work as a
disney prince or princess and spend time
with our soulmate however you might be
surprised to learn that two characters
who found love on the screen don't
always end up together in real life
that's because there's a lot of love in
the air but not between the right people
for example someone walked in on Belle
and Gaston making out when they saw that
person the princess asked them not to
tell the Beast who thought that these
two would end up together but that's not
the most ridiculous couple a woman who
works as the Disney princess revealed on
whisper that she had an affair with
Peter Pan and we hope that the young boy
did grow up before that mature
experience another person said that they
hooked up with Prince Charming every day
during lunch and another kiss Prince
Erik while Ariel was not there we also
heard about a girl who was in love with
Minnie Mouse when she was a kid and then
got engaged the woman who plays Minnie
Mouse at Disneyland even a guest got
involved when she said that she dated
the guy dressed as Peter Pan when she
was on vacation we guessed that this is
what happens when you work with people
who are too attractive the flashers did
you know why Splash Mountain is often
called flash Mountain that's something
no kid should know about but people who
work at Disney know that this is because
mature women have a little too much fun
on the ride and decide to take off their
shirt for their picture sometimes it's
not that bad and we can only see their
bra but then it is totally inappropriate
and no kid should ever see that this
joke was really popular in the 90s and
people even began posting these
ridiculous pictures online everyone
wanted to get a little wet on Splash
Mountain this is why Disney had to do
something about it they began hiring
employees to monitor the photos before
they could be seen on the big screen and
since they couldn't see the result of
their inappropriate joke women stopped
taking off their shirt on the ride it
was so effective that in 2009 Disney
didn't eat any employee to monitor the
pictures and we can imagine that it was
probably one of the weirdest
jobs in the world who thought that
people were looking at pictures of
topless women all day at Disney we just
hoped that they were old enough to do
this job and just because these
employees are not there anymore doesn't
mean that you should try to take off
your shirt the cat this is a really
surprising secret that only those who
stay in the park at night got the chance
to see every night at Disneyland when
guests come back home and cast members
leave work the park fills up again but
this time it's full of feral cats and
they aren't new cats have been living at
Disneyland shortly after it opened in
1955 people first tried to get rid of
them but it was almost impossible so
they found another solution they decided
to give them something to do in the park
their job is now to help control the
mouse population in Disneyland we just
hope that they won't chase Mickey Mouse
but anyway this character is too big for
them during the day the cats are
lounging in one of the five permanent
feeding stations in the park they also
pay people to take care of them and
whenever they have kittens they are put
up for adoption even if they are more
active during the night some guests have
also seen cats during the day isn't it
weird that Disney wants to get rid of
mice when their mascot is also a mouse
no matter what we would love to visit
the park at night simply to see the cat
if we were an animal we think that there
would be no better place to live than
Disneyland the characters from the
moment when you put on a costume - when
you take it off you have to be in
character that's the rule and it is
mostly important when you're around
guests we know that it's hot outside
when you're a mascot but this will never
be an excuse to show it this is also a
reason why cast members can never tell
their friends and family which character
they're playing and they can't talk
about their job either they don't have
the right to post any pictures online
and those who talked about their secrets
online did it anonymously so they
wouldn't get in trouble it means that if
you see your best friend dressed like
Cinderella at Disneyland she will have
to pretend that she doesn't know you
according to Disney everywhere inside
the park is the stage and outside the
park is backstage employees are called
cast members and customers are the
guests they use these names to make
people feel like they're always
performing and this is when the magic
happens however that doesn't mean that
your favorite Disney characters can't
make mistakes sometimes some guests have
seen Disney Princesses doing really
inappropriate things and they will
remember it forever this is why cast
members rather hide in the tunnels and
we'll talk about that soon the tunnels
the secret tunnels are really useful
when you want to walk through the park
and not have to perform and smile all
the time people think that their
underground
they're actually on the first floor of
the Magic Kingdom the whole park was
built over it so all the guests are
actually on the second floor the real
name of these secret tunnels is utila
door a cast member said that it was kind
of boring in some places but also creepy
in others no matter what when you're
there you feel like you're living
something unique this is also where you
can find the automatic vacuum assisted
collection system it is a series of
tubes that connect all the restaurants
to the central dump that is hidden
behind Splash Mountain this is why no
one can see cast members taking out the
smelly garbage in restaurants you can
also run seven of the old attractions
from the utili door there are also two
restaurants a barber shop and some
offices there isn't it weird to think
that all these secrets are hiding under
Magic Kingdom usually only cast members
are allowed to be there but some tour
guide also gave guests the chance to
visit the secret tunnels and we think
that it's going to be the next thing on
our list next time we visit Disneyland
the codes cast members know that bad
things can happen at Disneyland but they
don't want any guests to know it and
this is why they use secret codes for
example when they have to deal with an
annoying customer they can't just tell
them what they think this is why they
simply say have a Disney day now that we
know that we hope that we'll never hear
these words next time you visit
Disneyland with all the rides and the
food many children can also vomit during
the day this is when they get on the
radio and call code vie to make sure
that this little accident won't get too
much attention one of the most important
moments when they use a code is when a
child is lost however they don't want to
talk about the child because people will
know that a kid is lost without their
parents and they might try to kidnap
them this is why they talk about a lost
adult instead and if you're wondering
which character your friend is playing
it's possible that they simply answer
that they are friends with Mickey Mouse
for example there is another really
weird code that we don't want to hear it
is white powder alert and you'll want to
keep watching this video to know what it
means
the Asha's Disney might be more haunted
than you think
when you hear that there is a white
powder alert it doesn't mean that people
are using illegal substances it means
that people try to scatter a loved one's
ashes at the park and the reason why
there is a code for this is that it
happens all the time people are
emotionally connected to this place and
want the people they love to stay in
this magical place forever the first
people who did that were a tourist group
who asked to stay on the haunted mansion
for a little extra time so they could
hold a quick memorial for a boy who
passed away Disney gave them the
permission
but cast members were surprised when
they saw them sprinkling a powdery
substance all over the place they
probably didn't know that spreading
ashes is actually illegal and this is
why it's a really bad idea to do it at
Disneyland
many people ask if they can do that and
the answer is always no but those who
don't mind breaking the rules won't be
happy to hear about what happens to
their loved ones the ride will be shut
down and the guests will be evacuated so
an employee and protective clothing can
clean up the ashes with a special vacuum
so don't do it or you will just waste
your time and grandma will end up in a
vacuum anyway the club only the biggest
and richest Disney fans know about the
secret VIP lounge called club 33 years
ago Walt Disney built a secret hideaway
for celebrities and dignitaries it was
hidden behind a dull green door at the
top of the staircase in Disneyland's New
Orleans square the club was operational
for more than 40 years and served people
like Johnny Depp and Elton John but also
executives from big companies this is
where guests get the chance to live a
unique experience but only a few people
will really get the chance to know about
we only know that it is really beautiful
there is a nice bar to take a break away
from children and the food tastes
delicious
however if you would like to join you
won't be happy to hear that it's really
complicated first it will take about ten
years to get off the waiting list then
there are initiation fees worth ten
thousand dollars and you will also have
to pay thirty five hundred dollars every
year that you're a member
some rumors even say that the price is
actually twenty five thousand dollars
for the membership fees and twelve
thousand dollars in annual fees recently
club 33 expanded with four new clubs at
Disney World Park so it's probably a
little easier to be a part of it if we
had the money we would totally pay the
price to visit Disney's most mysterious
attraction the magic is not free after
all the underwear this is probably one
of the most disgusting things that ever
happened in Disneyland and we think that
it is worse than vomit cast members had
to share the same underwear that's
because many characters have to wear
Disney jockstraps tights or bike shorts
under their costume to make sure that
their regular underwear is not
noticeable but they have been passed
around as they had to turn in the
undergarments each night with the rest
of the costume before going home then
the next day they picked up a different
set that someone else wore the day
before Disney was supposed to clean them
in hot water but many people said that
the underwear was actually still smelly
and stained many employees complained
they were not comfortable with that but
Disney only listen to them when cast
members started getting pubic lice or
scabies over two years and we don't want
to see Rapunzel scratching herself down
there after an agreement with Disney
cast members finally got the right to
wear clean underwear they were assigned
individual undergarments and had the
right to bring them back home instead of
letting Disney clean them and we just
can't believe that they had to fight for
this basic right
it's sad to think that Disney wants
everything to look perfect on the
outside but they don't really care about
what cast members feel underneath the
plane did you know that Walt Disney had
a plane it's a twin turboprop plane with
Mickey Mouse on its tail when the
backlot tour existed yes even had the
chance to see it when they were on the
[ __ ]
at that time the recorded narration said
that it was known in airports across the
country as November 2 3 for Mickey but
most people just call it the mouse in
the 60s Disney used it when he was
scouting the Central Florida area to
build a second Park and also for many
other trips soon he began secretly
buying thousands of acres of land which
later became the Walt Disney World
Resort the mouse with the most used
executive aircraft in the country and it
finally retired in 1992 and cast members
still have the chance to see the plane
every day when they work because it is
on display backstage at Hollywood
studios it was originally parked in a
green area behind the residential street
but it is now behind the bleachers for
light motors action
unfortunately the mouse will never fly
again but we still love to see this
important part of Disney history and
that's it for 10 secrets revealed by
former Disney employees for more stories
like this make sure you watch ten
strange requirements to work as a Disney
Princess thanks for watching
[Music]